there's something really remarkable
about the human mind in that when it
sounds the alarms or it starts speaking
up stories and voices in our heads and
it's trying to get us away from
something it's scared of like a bunch of
kids calling you Fatso or a bunch of uh
teachers telling you that your grades
aren't good enough or a mom and dad
saying don't say that or you're going to
make your dad mad and or dude don't do
that again young man because your mom
gets really pissed off when you do that
and you learn at 7 years old that it's
your job to make sure Mom and Dad are
okay when that
happens um and you avoid those
situations your body wins because it
stayed alive it avoided them and what
does it do it reinforces those voices it
makes the alarms louder and louder and
louder